preparing breakfast for his guests under
normal circumstances Mustapha guden
wouldn't have time for this when it's
high season in Antalya the hotel owners
usually run off his feet but not this
year
right now only one of his rooms is
occupied a family from Germany is here
despite the travel warning they love it
I can only tell you come here everyone
it's wonderful in Antalya the only
problem is because of the coronavirus
crisis hardly anyone is coming last year
I had an occupancy rate of 100%
consistently from April to October and
this year there are only these three
people July is coming soon we only have
a few months left of this season it's
really difficult it's all set up
mustafa has done everything he can to
make his hotel safe the Turkish
government has issued strict hygiene
rules
that's why guden now disinfects rooms
and pool chairs several times a day
although nobody is using them it must
get video we have masks for yes you can
disinfect your hands everywhere and
temperature checks are scheduled every
day requirements are very strict and we
adhere to what good is that if no one
comes to the silver Italia's beaches are
among the most popular holiday
destinations in the Mediterranean region
about 15 million tourists from abroad
came here last year but this summer most
of the Sun Loungers are empty because of
the coronavirus crisis governments in
Europe including Germany are warning
their citizens against travel to Turkey
many of those here who depend on tourism
think that's unfair
almost 2.5 million people live in the
entire region but so far only a few
hundred coronavirus infections have been
officially registered here Moustafa
Gordon thinks turkey is coming through
the crisis relatively well he believes
decision makers in Europe are
deliberately warning against trips to
Turkey in order to give their own
tourist destinations and advantage
Germany acted very biased they declared
us a risk area but open borders to
countries that are in a much worse
situation Spain or Italy for example
they have more coronavirus cases than
turkey and a higher coronavirus - talk a
lot of choke Buddhist is a joke many
share Gordon's frustration Italia's
historic old town is normally filled
with tourists bartering facilities now
the sellers fight Gordon restaurant
owners and taxi drivers are wondering
how long they can keep going
we only have a third of our taxis on the
streets no hotel guests no taxi rides
for sure it doesn't work without foreign
tourists Turkish holidaymakers aren't
enough for this all our preparations for
this summer were for nothing 2020 is a
lost year a lost year maybe last season
he made good money with his hotel
Mustapha guden says and he's still
hopeful but he also knows if the
tourists from Europe don't come back
soon the holiday paradise of Antalya
faces a devastating summer correspondent
Yulia hon fathers report for us and it's
now standing by an astable yulia many
people are wondering whether it is
actually safe to travel to Turkey right
now what's your impression the Turkish
government is trying hard to convince
travelers and political decision-makers
in Europe that Turkey is a safe
destination this summer they're actively
lobbying a number of EU countries to
open their borders lifts travel warnings
to third countries like Turkey Ankara
has also launched a so-called healthy
tourism program setting out criteria for
health and hygiene in airplanes airports
also in hotels restaurants cafes or at
beaches and hotel owner mustapha told me
that the authorities are actually very
strict when it comes to making sure
these rules are being followed at
entires Airport for example we saw
thermal cameras checking passengers
temperatures they're also working on
setting up a coronavirus test center
there so many things are being done but
then we also have to look at the numbers
right and I mentioned in my report that
the coastal tourism hubs there in Turkey
have seen relatively low coronavirus
cases but overall in the countries the
numbers are surging they have actually
doubled compared compared to early June
when Turkey lifted most of its
coronavirus restrictions we're now at
nearly 1,500 new cases per day and
that's probably something European
decision making
we'll take into consideration when
re-evaluating their travel advice or
warnings oh you remind us just how
important is the travel industry for
Turkey it's a billion dollar a business
and that's exactly why the Turkish
government presses to open borders
tourism accounts for 12% of the Turkish
economy an economy that is now facing
the second recession in just two years
time so Turkey needs foreign tourists it
needs foreign currencies the sector here
the season has already been battered by
the pandemic
there have been coronavirus forced
shutdowns since late March till the end
of May so this has affected the lives of
thousands tens of thousands of people
working in tourism and this is why this
summer is so crucial there's so much at
stake here for Turkey what about the
German Travel Warning for Turkey that's
still in place is this straining
relations between the two countries
well Germany doesn't just have this
Travel Warning for Turkey but for many
countries outside the European Union
so-called third countries but because
turkey is so important for holiday
makers from Germany and Germany also has
a large population with a Turkish
background these people want to come
here in summer spend their holiday here
visit their relatives this has somehow
turn into a political issue it certainly
has potential for conflict we know that
the Turkish government is very unhappy
about this German travel warning
although they are very carefully
phrasing their criticism let's listen to
what Turkey's foreign minister may blue
Charu shaloo had to say about this
recently we are disappointed that some
countries extended the travel advisories
for turkey or published list classified
turkey as a risky destination there is
no objective and scientific reason in
these steps turkey has proven itself in
its fight against poet 19 German
authorities on the other hand say we
have to monitor how the outbreak
here in Turkey it develops they also say
they don't want to bring back German
citizens who are stuck somewhere abroad
be it in Turkey or elsewhere if the
situation worsens but some also say this
might not just be about the pandemic but
maybe also about politics because German
Turkish relations are still strained
there are a number of contentious issues
the Syria crisis Libya the refugee issue
all the human rights situation here in
Turkey so some say this travel warning
might also be a means for Germany to
seek some political concessions CW
correspondent Yulia Hahn in Istanbul
thank you very much for this analysis
now to some other coronavirus related
news around the world officials in the
english beach town of Bournemouth have
declared a major incident after massive
crowds flocked there in hot weather
authorities said ignoring public health
guidance on the coronavirus was
irresponsible the declaration allows
them to initiate an emergency response
including the deployment of additional
police patrols